sur la fourniture de gaz russe vladimir
poutine mais la pression sur les pays
dits inamicaux et pose ses conditions
si ces paiements ne sont pas effectués
en roubles nous considérons qu'il s'agit
d'un défaut de paiement de la part des
acheteurs
autrement dit les contrats existants
seront arrêtés
privé l'europe de gaz une menace lourde
au même moment berlin et paris le
réaffirme payer en roubles c'est non je
vous confiant que les contrats en euros
doivent être payés en euros et seront
payés en europe quelles conséquences de
ce bras de fer entre monnaies
le gaz russe représente 40 % des
approvisionnements en europe
17% en france
l'arrêt des livraisons mettrait donc en
danger l'approvisionnement de certaines
entreprises selon cet expert pourriez
voir des délestages c'est-à-dire des
coupures de gaz qui n'était pas prévu
parce que on n'a pas suffisamment gaz à
fournir du fait que la russie coupé les
livraisons plus de gaz russe cela
signifie aussi des stocks moins remplis
et des difficultés à passer l'hiver
prochain
alors cette menace d'une coupure brutale
est elle crédible à contractuellement
elle n'est pas crédible mais encore une
fois personne ne sait ce que vladimir
poutine veut faire et il pourrait être
amené à le faire du jour au lendemain et
nous devons nous y préparer nous serons
obligés d'accélérer notre transition
énergétique pour trouver du gaz ailleurs
et trouver des alternatives au gaz aller
chercher du gaz dans d'autres pays au
qatar en algérie en espagne ou en
norvège et relancer le charbon paris et
berlin ont indiqué se préparer au pire
des scénarios